so arcane ended this past weekend but
literally who cares because they'll let
riot finally drop some new footage of
their upcoming fighting game project now
now project l isn't ready for release
just yet and i mean it doesn't even have
a real name yet but that little bit of
footage we saw actually revealed a ton
of information about the game some of
which they didn't even talk about on
stream and at the risk of sounding
excited for a riot game project l looks
like it could be really [ __ ] good
[Music]
okay before we talk about project l i
just want to make sure that you're all
sub to the channel so please if you
aren't already hit the sub button and
turn on notifications because it really
does help okay so in case you missed the
news riot has finally shown off project
l their upcoming league of legends
fighting game this game has been in
various stages of development for a
really long time and at one point it was
called the worst kept secret in fighting
games officially it was announced at evo
2019 and we got the tiniest amount of
footage in october 2019 but hardcore
fans have been waiting for this game
since 2016. see five whole years ago
riot bought radiant entertainment a dev
studio run by tom and tony cannon the
founders of evo who back then were
working on a game called rising thunder
rising thunder is actually still
playable and it's a pretty cool game but
the idea was that it's a fighting game
that you can play on a keyboard each
character had special moves you could
use with one button and they were all
tied to cooldowns sort of like league of
legends right anyway radiant got bought
and everyone immediately assumed that
riot was working on a fighting game with
them and lo and behold we were all right
and now that we've finally seen the damn
thing it actually looks pretty cool okay
so let's get the big obvious project l
stuff out of the way i'm gonna try my
best to communicate all this information
in such a way that hopefully if you
don't play fighting games this could
help you understand why you might want
to be excited for this game and please
forgive me if i get to fighting game
nerdy project l which doesn't have a
name yet is a 2v2 tag fighter that means
you pick two characters to bring into a
game and you can swap between them at
the press of a button this is inspired
by the versus series of games made most
popular by marvel vs capcom 2 which used
a 3v3 system but plenty of games have
been 2v2 including marvel vs capcom
infinite street fighter cross tekken
tekken tag tournament even skullgirls
gives you an option of playing a two
character team like some of those games
and
unlike other ones of those games project
l has an assist mechanic at any time
during a match you can press an assist
button to call your non-active character
out onto the battlefield to do one of
their attacks this can help make longer
combos or you know open your opponent up
into neutral it's really versatile we
don't know if this game has a
traditional marvel 2 style assist system
where characters have a predetermined
list of assists you get to choose from
before you start a set or if this is
more like skull girls where any move the
character has can be the one assist you
choose or if characters have access to
multiple assists in one set sort of like
in blade's blue crosstag battle what we
do know is that each character seems to
have access to multiple different kinds
of assists
and that there is some amount of ability
to cancel into your tag during a combo
that means that this combo you're seeing
right now is only possible because echo
can actually cancel his button into
tagging into ari which is gonna open up
some insane combos and folks
they showed off some pretty sweet combos
i'm not usually a heavy grappler kind of
player but darius has some absolutely
insane stuff including this crazy wall
bounce charge attack combo by the way
that was one of the little hidden
mechanics they showed off but didn't
talk about we don't know if it's a
system level thing or just a passive
ability that darius has but they showed
him holding down and charging a button
multiple times strengthening the attack
and those charged attacks get a lot
stronger the combos they showed imply
that darius can do things like dash up
and combo after charged buttons that
otherwise don't lead into anything
speaking of darius what they did use him
to show off explicitly was project l's
input system because unlike traditional
fighting games project l is using single
button based inputs for special moves
instead of motion inputs basically this
means that instead of doing a quarter
circle on your movement input of choice
and then pressing a button to do a
special move it's more like smash where
just pressing a special move button and
maybe a single direction at the same
time will get you what you're looking
for personally i'm not the biggest fan
of this and i've seen a lot of people
feel the same way i'd rather this be an
option sort of like in grand blue
fantasy but i understand that like
rising thunder part of the goal here is
probably to make a fighting game that
you can play easily with your keyboard i
imagine this game is probably gonna have
a ton of league of legends players
flooding in to try it when it comes out
and making sure that they can play this
game with the same inputs they use to
play league is really important and
smash has shown that you don't need
motion inputs to create a deep and
complex battle system i just way prefer
quarter circles to single inputs because
my brain is wired that way after playing
fighting games for 20 years the canon
said that they want to make sure that
this input style doesn't impact the
skill sealing of project owl now let's
talk about controls
i know that a lot of you have strong
opinions about mechanical difficulty in
fighting games
for project l we're embracing the easy
to learn hard to master mentality
so yes we are making it easier to jump
in with a new character and learn their
basic kit
that said we absolutely believe in
rewarding the time you spend going deep
on a character and providing
opportunities for you to showcase your
high-end mastery and i trust that they
know what they're talking about this is
just one thing that i'm watching out for
i guess from my perspective i think it's
really important that league and valor
players can just pick up this game and
play it without having to learn motion
inputs at the same time i think it's
equally important that the fgc at large
gets really into this game and i think
that it would have an easier time of
doing that if it had the option of
choosing between quarter circles and
single buttons i mean guilty gear and
granblue did it and i imagine riot is
working with bigger budgets than our
system works anyway that aside there are
a few other cool mechanics they showed
off most of the footage they showed was
about echo who looks like a really cool
character design basically his kit
revolves around chrono strike a forward
moving attack that leaves behind an
after image for a small amount of time
after inputting chronostrike you can
input it again to teleport to the after
image's current location one this looks
really cool but two and more importantly
it's got me thinking about all the cool
gameplay options it opens up it's pretty
clear that its main purpose is to be a
cool combo extender which they showed it
doing a few times but they also show
echo using it to stay safe after some
pressure which is interesting but what's
really exciting to me is the mix-up
potential like think about this scenario
we see a version of chronostrike that
isn't an attack it's just a roll echo
can use that to switch sides he also has
a slow moving arcing projectile in time
winder we also see an aria assist that
has her drop some projectiles sort of
like a mini version of amaterasu's cold
star assist in marvel 3. all that
combined can theoretically lead to some
really nasty mix-ups with echo i mean
just think about the scenario you knock
the opponent down you toss timewinder
and you call arya assist and then you
roll now as they wake up they have to
block the grenade block ari and then
they have to guess which side echo is
going to be on left or right and if he
has a fast low hitting move they also
have to guess between a low and a throw
on top of that and i know i know i'm
theorycrafting a game that isn't even
out yet but this is the kind of stuff
that gets me excited about project l
they showed off just enough to tell me
that this game is being made by fighting
game players for fighting game players
who want to think about this kind of
stuff but that does give me some pause
because tag fighters are notoriously
difficult to learn and play not just
because you have to learn two characters
at once to play at a confident level but
also because that mix-up i just
described is often the backbone of
high-level play left-right high-low
mix-ups happen all the time in versus
games characters are fast and deal a lot
of damage stuff moves quickly and can be
overwhelming because the knowledge
checks are often immense i know that i
said that it's important for this game
that the fgc at large gets into it if it
wants to succeed but i also think it's
important that a casual fan who is a
league player doesn't hop online for the
first time only to get mixed by a
champion they already hate like yumi or
something then again marvel 2 and 3 sold
really well to casual audiences so maybe
i'm worrying about nothing here anyway
there are some more cool things they
showed that they didn't explicitly talk
about like did you notice that the ahri
loop they showed multiple times appears
to have a hard limit of three reps it
looks like those fox fire fireballs
chitros hover around her and each one
she tosses doesn't return to her we
never actually see them come back to her
during the footage they showed so i
don't know if they're supposed to
automatically regenerate over time or if
she turns them on with a special move
like in league or if they're tied to her
super since we see her do spirit rush
between the fireballs in the loop
another cool thing i picked up on was
that they showed either a perfect block
or parry mechanic there is a moment
where we see ari bust through an attack
from darius and there's enough hits done
on this parry that ari has time to dash
up and then punish which is pretty nice
unclear if it's a system level thing or
if just ahri has parries but either way
it seems like it could be a pretty
strong defensive mechanic the last
little nerdy thing i'll mention before
the next big point is that echo shows
off a lot of movement his forward dash
and back dash look like they cover a lot
of distance but he also shows off a
marvel style wave dash retaining
momentum after cancelling his dash into
a crouch he also shows a little bit of
air movement too like i can't tell if
this is a double jump or an undernight
style air hop but more movement options
are always appreciated the other big
thing the canons talked about was
netcode they're promising that this game
is gonna run really well online which
boy i hope that's true for project l
we've designed our entire networking
stack to deliver the same highly
responsive gameplay that you'd get
playing offline
of course this starts by using rollback
networking at the core
rollback does a great job of maintaining
a consistent low input delay across a
wide range of pings
we've also developed a new networking
model that enhances the benefits of
rollback with core technology developed
by other games at riot
we'll route network traffic between
players through riot direct our internal
network already being used to minimize
latency in league of legends in mallory
they're saying that project l is going
to run on some of the same online
architecture that league and valerie use
which does bode well because it's not
exactly like those games are known for
having horrible net code issues another
plus in their column is that tony cannon
created ggpo an online fighting game
rollback netcode that some fighting
games still use one of the reasons i
hope that this game does run well online
and riot makes good on all these
promises is that if the netcode is good
other fighting game developers might
just have to step up netcode has been a
really hot topic in the fgc over the
last couple of years after kovis shut
down in-person tournaments and we're all
stuck playing online street fighter 5
tekken 7 even smash ultimate these games
are [ __ ] horseshit to play online to
different extents obviously but it is
not a good time in any of them there
have been some advancements guilty gear
runs well and fans created slippy to
make melee function well online but
those aren't the standard just yet my
hope is that if project l succeeds
partially on the back of strong net code
other fighting game developers will be
scared of losing their player base to
riot and step up their game in response
and honestly that's true of a lot of
things with project out project l
represents the first time in a long time
that a large developer with a lot of
money is putting in the effort to try to
capture fighting game fans that should
scare folks at companies like capcom and
namco into making sure that street
fighter 6 and tekken 8 don't disappoint
people so they don't go off and play
project l instead and look to be honest
i don't really want to be seeing the
praises of riot games here let's not
forget that they're still mired in
scandal over fostering an environment
where women were allegedly harassed and
there was a co who walked around
grabbing people's balls this is not a
company i want to celebrate but the
reason i'm still a little bit hopeful
for this game is that it seems like it's
being made by fighting game fans for
fighting game fans honestly it's nice to
see people who love fighting games get
to make what looks like a love letter to
a community that often gets the short
end of the stick when it comes to stuff
like this i think about arcane that show
was gorgeous and it sucks knowing that
animators were underpaid while making it
and that the money came from a company
with as much allegedly gross stuff going
on as ryan but at the same time it was
hard not to admire what happens when
passionate talented people get basically
infinite time and budget to make
something incredible fighting games
don't get that we get horrible launches
and nickel and dime dlc and terrible
communication and 17-year load times and
people telling us that our favorite
characters are just functions my hope is
that project l like arcane and valor
before it is being made by a group of
people who come from a community that
they care about and are being given the
time and money to make something truly
special for that community
even if they have to take money from
riot to do it but hey that's just me let
me know in the comments if you're
excited for this thing or if the riot
connection turns you off or you really
want to see motion inputs in this game
in the meantime i'm going to go write
about 5 000 emails to the canons asking
them when they're going to put galio in
this game
do you think they're ever going to get
you know the you know how they keep
doing lego star wars and lego hair yeah
they ever gonna get lego league of
legends yeah lego legends
it seems just really straightforward
just do it you know lego legends of
runeterra
we if riot if you want that you have to
pay me and danny
if you want that mark merrill pay up
no i'm you're in on this you're you're
on the ride you are in the room you're
in on the ride